Ho ho ho, and Merry Christmas. The amazing people over at originpc.com
wanted me to tell you that if you're looking to get some PC upgrades and gear that will bring you
holiday
cheer
*sniff laugh*
When you purchase select systems you can get free, for free three-day expedited shipping on
On selected laptops only, your choice of free $50 Amazon gift card or a selected Sound Blaster
x5 headset Or free digital copy of Destiny 2 - with select systems with qualifying
NVIDIA GPUs, that's all check out originpc.com; it's a great website
I'm so excited to finally get my computer from them as well, and that's it, enjoy the video
*grunting*
I have returned
*maniacal laughter*
You thought I was going to give up, didn't you
Well think again everybody 'cause I'm back
Do not ride snake. They say I say, but whatever
Whatever. So how do I how do I do this?
How does it work. I have a feeling I'm gonna be here a while.
Oh wow
Okay, you can really launch yourself because it's a flexi bucket
That's easy, I figured that out with my IQ - AH MY EYES ARE BURNING
All by myself...
People struggling in this bit needs to realize
*screams*
Don't even care; watch this
Fine, fine, I know what I must do. The challenge is easy, the mission is hard my penis
Bucket for fuck's sake man. I gotta watch it stop dangling now
Nope Jesus, okay, we're fine
Just gotta wait for it to stop dangling meanwhile. I will go into my nether realm
(Captions up to this moment created by Pyvonix and AestheticPlayz)
Channeling my Chakra!
As a great man once said:
Bitches are nice people
God damn it
goddamnit
*sigh from in game*
Watch this...
Watch this
watch this
Watch this...
OH MY-
*Chuckles*
*Heavy Laughter*
HYEUGH
I did it
I did it (idk it was a mumble)
Ha-ha-How do you do that?
*Laughing*
Oh my god
OH MY GOD!
*Continued Laughter*
*This laughter hurts my ears*
*Wheezing*
I AM
THE BEST PLAYER
IN THE WORLD
It's not because I am the best, it's because...
I practice in real life
IRL
IRL apparently you gotta climb up this now isn't that great
Apparently you gotta climb up this now. Isn't that great?
what that fuck is this?
what that fuck is this this is the slipperiest surface?
This is the slipperiest surface
I have ever seen.
Wow
oh
Oh wow, oh wow
This...
Edgar, Edgar, Edgar
Edgar.
Edgar
Daddy's working, I have the biggest mouse pad...
in my heart
It exists in my heart. My mouse pad is so large.
It works at Nintendo. I had the largest mouse pad just think about how big your mouse pad is readers
Everyone is so impressed by the size of your mouse pad.
Oh wow a small slip won't matter much as long as you block out the haters
There won't be anyone left
It won't be anyone left
Look at that shit dude. Dude you're a talent. You're a beast
You're a lion
Just think about how big your mousepad is
It's so big
You have the largest mousepad
Oh oh, whoa, whoa oh great.
Oh fantastic
Why don't we hear him say some stupid sh- about it? Huh?
Huh why is this stupid voice over volume? What do you got to say about that Mr. Foddy?
As long as I don't fall down from here. You know what whatever
Whatever, doesn't matter
*Singing*
What the hell dude? I don't understand
I don't- I mean- I don't understand a lot of things, but I do understand that we're getting close
*whispers*
Getting close I can smell it
Why the heckeri dude? Like why, why, what'd I do huh, what'd I do huh? What'd I do, huh?
Did I hurt you?
Why am I singing Les Misérables? Why?
Stop sliding if the if everyone stopped sliding the world would be a better place, you know who said that
Alfonzo you know that hey, you know the guy everyone knows an Alfanso. I am out of mouse pad
So I'm just gonna drag myself this way. Oh God my keyboard is in the way. Uhh that's fine. That's fine. Let's just redo that
Jesus christ
You're complaining about your mouse pad Pewds what are you a baby? Okay?
So you don't sound like a baby when you say that okay sure buddy sure you know who invented the mouse pad
That's right, Jesus Christ. That's why I'm a Christian channel get with the times
Stop oh my god. What are you made out of slippery slope?
Come on Felix. You can do this remember your name Felix. All right, I remember
What the hell dude
What the hell dude that is not the good?
Stop a sliding have I told you the story about how the mousepad was invented. It was in Croatia back in
One guy was like man
That's slippery
Matt how that's the story I think you hit like a sweet spot in some places
Cuz like is it angling more and more is what I'm asking
That's all I want to know oh, actually you know we could actually make it up
Why do I speak
Oh oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god come on Felix
Uhh
*scream of relief*
*another scream of relief*
I am the one! Oh it feels Goood
Okay, okay, okay, okay? This is so nerve-racking. Oh my god stay there
Woo!
Are you kidding me right now-
Narrator: Have you thought about who you are in this?
Narrator: Are you the man in the pot Diogenes
Narrator: Are you the top of the hammer?
Okay
Narrator: I think not where your hand moves, the hammer may not follow
How about you invest into a pop filter. How about that?
Narrator: Nor the man, nor the man's hand
Okay.
Narrator: In this you are his will. His intent he embodied with-
Listen. You made a hard game
Okay, calm down calm down
Oh my god
No no no... Jesus Christ. Hey, it didn't rhyme everybody
Ooh, this is ridiculous
Oh
Aah
Mmm
*Continued moaning*
Ooh
Oh my god the lag, did you see that? Jesus Christ
I did it! I'm almost at the top! Get out of my way mmm thing
You better not fucking launch me to some stupid...
*Heavy sigh of relief*
Where the hell am I?
Look at that, I'm so good at this game
Shut the Ff-
Yeah, I did. I- I conquered
Yes I did- Uh okay- Listen... Yes
What else
Where do you think
Yup
Well that's kind of sweet
Don't do that Felix, don't do that
Oh
Oh my god
Jebus Christ. Did you see that? the skill.
Can I grab? Yes
Can I stay on it?
Damn it
Oh, I can't bend it. It's stuck
Oh, I guess I can
Oh my god
My head is burning up by the way. It's so hot I'm dying.
I will conquer
Oh my god you almost just cucked yourself
Jesus Christ dude.
I gotta launch, I gotta launch, okay
That shouldn't be hard, right?
Whoa what just happened. What is happening?
What that can I know oh okay this guy
Oooh
Am I going back down again? No no no don't go back
Down
I'm alone
Ooah
I'm shitting myself. What is happening?
I'm in space
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOH ahahahahahahaha
*Now that he beat the game, he enters a state of euphoria*
That was easy, I did it, leave a like
Get this to trending(#PewdiepieBeatsGOI) if you ever thought I couldn't do it
Or if I thought I could do it get this trending (#PewdiepieBeatsGOI). This is it come on
COME ON
Thank god, I can get rid of this Sledgehammer has been in my room for the past weeks
I didn't think I would actually make the game
There were some parts that were so difficult
That I was like there's just no way and I just kept going with this mean like I was gonna keep going no matter what?
But on the I- on the other end I was ready to give up so many times you have no idea
I mean, it's a game like who gives a shit, but at the same time. It was it was fun to see all you guys
Interaction within like will he make it or come on you you don't give up keep going and all that shit. It's cool
I really I had a lot of fun playing this game. Thanks to Bennett Foddy for making such a
unique and uh...
Incredible game, and that's it for me. Goodbye, brofist!